[Music]
[Music]
heartland is ubisoft's new free-to-play
spin-off from the division universe
very little has been shared from the
studio but industry insider tom
henderson has been sharing information
that has been assisting in keeping the
interest alive
previously he has provided information
on heartland that is at least given some
sort of insight on the type of game
we'll be seeing released hopefully
sometime soon
heartland is based in the small town
setting of silver creek in the state of
new york
much like the base games there will be a
base of operations where players can
customize loadouts match make for
lobbies sell previously extracted loot
buy upgrades and new weapons
there will be classes that can be chosen
from that will provide unique talents
and perks like weapon expert medic and
survivalist
previously we had been told about two
game modes storm and excursion
excursion is a pve mode pitting players
against ai it has been described as a
way to prepare agents for the storm mode
the description provided says explore
alongside other friendly agents to
prepare the world for the incoming storm
storm is essentially the same thing but
it is pve vp
players should recognize this from the
dark zone that is present in both the
division and its sequel
however in the last day or so there have
been further updates released heartlands
will now feature four game modes
excursion storm nightfall and hunt
as stated earlier excursion is a pve
mode that is aimed at getting you
prepared for storm
in this mode players need to scavenge
loot explore and survive against enemy
ai with the objective of extracting from
the map via helicopter
storm heartland's flagship game mode
this is pretty much excursion except
with other players as well as ai
teams are composed of three players
where they can explore loot and scavenge
the large open world map
the gameplay could be compared to escape
from tarkov or hunt showdown where the
goal is to survive loot and extract from
silver creek to your base of operations
the aim is to earn more powerful gear to
take on greater challenges
as there are other players about these
upgrades will help you be better
prepared for these encounters
the map is a large open world where
players can explore and find loot dotted
throughout
much like the division you'll find loot
in five different rarities gray green
blue purple and gold
another feature of the map that is
relatively common in these br style
games is the release of deadly gas
around the map
this could be the virus similar to the
contaminated areas that we find in the
base game or perhaps it could be
something like dc 62 which was released
in washington dc
however rather than spreading from the
outside of the map and slowly creeping
in these contaminated areas can pop up
anywhere
in order to avoid being downed by this
players can craft gas mask filters in
order to survive gas-ridden areas
nightfall is the third heartland mode
that is an objective-based pve mode
just like with storm players need to
loot up survive and extract your base of
operations
nightfall however is a little different
with added layers to increase the
difficulty of the mode this mode
requires players to complete objectives
throughout the playthrough
some of these objectives include
deploying beacons tracking down targets
and collecting agent data
unlike storm players cannot extract with
a helicopter and instead need to extract
via an extraction point on foot at the
edge of the map
the catch players cannot extract from
silver creek at nightfall and need to
survive the night against the ai called
vultures
sadly not too much is known about hunt
but sources have suggested that this
mode is more pvp-based with no ai on the
map
in addition to these new modes sources
have confirmed several other key details
including that the division heartland
will feature cross play also the
inventory and gear system has had a huge
overhaul making it more familiar to what
we're used to in the division 1 and 2.
i mean this is a free to play game and a
lot of pve players have stated that they
have absolutely no interest in this
because it has been stated that this is
primarily focused on pvp
but with this news update there are now
a couple of pve options out there and
it's free so if you're a fan of the
franchise what do you have to lose in
trying it out i'm personally waiting to
see how this will expand on the universe
especially from a lower point of view
and if it doesn't i'm sure i'll be able
to fill in the gaps either way i'll be
jumping in to give it a go
yes obviously being free to play there
will be a bunch of micro transactions
and i know this is a dirty word and all
but the other games have shown that they
focus more around vanity items rather
than pay to win options so until i'm
showing otherwise i'm not concerned
about this
anyway this was just a quick update as
i've stated before any work going into
the expansion of the division universe
i'm happy so fingers crossed we have
something good coming with heartland
thanks for watching cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]